tvm also video blogging Davos and my
answer to a question is very very simple
that's what Davis is all about I think
what everybody should do in 2008 to have
a world make have become a better place
is to think outside of our box and
outside of our own current environment
mine is technology and I focus too much
on that but learn about everything else
happening so try to focus on Africa try
to focus on environment on energy which
are all the topics discussed here and
then bring into a global conversation
and understand what how we can help and
generally what we our tendencies to be
too much focused on our own environment
so that would be my things to you know
open your mind and try and focus like an
hour or two or more day on something
else and what we can bring like Nicholas
Negroponte for example you know creating
the one laptop per child pc of years ago
and I get it now that's fantastic so
that that's well